dieser mann hier ja genau der den du
gerade auf diesem bild sehen kannst das
ist egal
liga nie ist eine regelrechte
weltsensation
[Musik]
ein schuldiger ist katz erhalt mensch
wiedergeboren worden sei hieß es
der erste mensch der tod und
gleichzeitig am leben ist
egal wer mit einem südkoreanischen
krankenhaus nun schon seit mehr als vier
jahren von jeglichem kontakt mit der
außenwelt abgeschirmt und niemand wagt
es seinen wahren gesundheitszustand zu
verraten
und jetzt fragt ihr euch sicher warum
eigentlich wer ist dieser mann nun wir
reden hier über keinen geringeren als
den vorstandsvorsitzenden von samsung
einem der reichsten männer der welt an
den tag an dem er stirbt wird sein sohn
zwischen 10 und 15 milliarden dollar
und gleich im anschluss wird er 65
prozent davon als erbschaftssteuer an
die südkoreanische regierung zahlen
müssen und ja ich weiß was ihr euch
jetzt vielleicht fragt was ist das
problem wer würde nicht gerne 35 prozent
von 15 milliarden dollar haben wollen
glaubt mir am ende dieses videos werdet
ihr sehr gut verstehen warum sein sohn
ganz und gar nicht möglich ist über
dieses milliarden erbe und ihr werdet
vielleicht sogar zugeben dass ihr nicht
wirklich wissen wollt ob er tatsächlich
tot oder am leben ist klingt alles sehr
verworren nicht warten
lasst uns loslegen und die dinge
entwerten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geld jene besondere sache von der can i
west am liebsten so schnell wie möglich
so viel wie möglich loswerden will
was ihr glaubt mir nicht kann seht euch
bitte mal folgende meldungen
wenn herr west und kim kardashian geben
fast eine million euro vergoldet
toiletten aus genau wie ihr seht gibt es
nun mal läutet es hassen geld auf dem
konto zu haben
umgekehrt gibt es auch viele die geld
durchaus lieben und in diese letzte
gruppe fallen die meisten milliardäre
die reichsten menschen auf diesem
planeten
dies mag zwar eine sehr kleine gruppe
von menschen seien aber sie wächst von
tag zu tag
2017 steigt die zahl der milliardäre
weltweit auf 2754 für das starke
wachstum der zahl von milliardären gibt
es eine einfache erklärung
schwellenländern plötzlich fing länder
wie china und vietnam an ihre eigenen
milliardäre zu generieren und ihr
fahrzeug leicht sind dies nun gute oder
schlechte nachrichten
nun es kommt darauf an wen sie fragen
laut gabriel sack mit einem
marxistischen wirtschaftswissenschaftler
ist dies zum beispiel ein verdammt
großes problem gut aber lasst uns an
dieser stelle mal einen kurzen abstecher
machen
ich habe sicher schon mal von der einen
oder anderen verschwörungstheorie gehört
in der behauptet wird die mainstream
medien versuchten alle kritiker des
kapitalismus zum schweigen zu bringen
nicht wahr
trotzdem werden von ebendiesen
mainstream-medien sowohl gabriel
sackmann als auch vom city als die neuen
antikapitalistischen rockstars gefeiert
sie schafften es sogar auf das cover des
bloomberg magazins
[Musik]
und zwar nicht als bösewicht sondern als
die guten also denk dran wenn ihr das
nächste mal wieder irgendeinen
klugscheißern mit dieser
verschwörungstheorie ankommt aber kommen
wir zurück zu unserer geschichte was ist
laut sagt man das problem mit
milliardären
sie zerstören die soziale mobilität und
was bedeutet soziale mobilität das ist
der akademische begriff für den
amerikanischen traum denkmal eine
sekunde darüber nach es ist schwer vom
tellerwäscher zum millionär aufzusteigen
wenn ihr mit jemandem konkurrieren müsst
der schon stinkreich geboren wurde und
dadurch die besten unis besuchen konnte
viele ökonomen zufolge nimmt die
konzentration der großen geldvermögen
immer weiter zu sie behaupten eine
kleine elite dort besäße fast alles
haben sie damit recht das ist schwer zu
sagen
tatsächlich gibt es bisher keine
möglichkeit die soziale mobilität
effektiv zu messen es gibt also gute
argumente auf beiden seiten aber fakt
ist dass argumentation gewinnt immer
weiter an einfluss unsere heutige frage
lautet also sollten wir die reichen
nicht stärker besteuern gibt es länder
die dies bereits praktizieren und wie
gut funktioniert dort eine solche steuer
politik und was hat er lebende tote boss
von samsung mit all dem zu tun
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir dies tun
werfen wir noch schnell einen blick in
die geschichte des die reichen
niemand mag steuererhöhungen aber wenn
du jetzt nicht gerade zb stefan quandt
heißt du wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht
besonders nervös werden wenn das thema
reichensteuer für milliardäre zur
sprache kommt falls doch dann herr
stephan aus dem fragst du dich ja
vielleicht was milliardäre so davon
halten mögen wenn sie steuern zahlen
müssen
es könnte dich wirklich überrascht
[Musik]
buffett und bill gates sich einig dass
reiche höhere steuern zahlen sollten
ja das habt ihr richtig verstanden aber
wartet einen moment denn dieser
vorschlag milliardäre höher zu besteuern
ist komplizierter als es scheint sie
wollen nicht nur eine höhere
einkommenssteuer wir reden auch über
eine vermögenssteuer und das ist sehr
wichtig denn ein großes vermögen ist die
eine sache ein hohes einkommen eine
andere und passt gut auf der nächst
geben wir euch den schlüssel zum
verständnis des hauptproblem
nehmen wir zb bill gates sein vermögen
beträgt rund 103 milliarden dollar
[Musik]
aber deutlich lichter kann darüber nicht
in bar verfügen wenn wir einen blick auf
sein bankkonto werfen könnten würden wir
dort bei weitem nicht so viel geld sehen
aber wo befindet sich dann sein ganzes
geld die antwort liegt in seinen
anlagewerten wertvollen dingen die
häusern kunstwerken und natürlich
microsoft-aktien dies bedeutet dass wenn
microsoft aktien plötzlich an der
verlieren würden würde auch bill gates
reichtum ein wenig abschwächen
deshalb handelt es sich jedes mal wenn
er hört dass das vermögen eines
milliardärs so oder so hoch ist nun mal
um eine schätzung tatsächlich ist es
wirklich schwer den reichtum von
milliardären genau zu messen und das ist
der grund warum vorschläge wie der
folgende so viele debatten auslösen
[Musik]
ich habe einen plan salat elizabeth
warren diskutiert über die
vorgeschlagene vermögenssteuer und
weitere themen in cedar rapids im moment
zahlen reiche leute in den usa steuern
wie jeder andere auch einkommenssteuer
auf ihr einkommen und mehrwertsteuer auf
ihre konsumausgaben bei einer künftigen
vermögenssteuer müssten sie jedes jahr
zwischen 2 und 3 prozent ihres
nettovermögens an den fiskus abführen
auch wenn sie ihr geld in dem jahr
überhaupt nicht angehört haben und ja
wir reden nicht nur über bargeld sondern
über alle arten von vermögenswerten die
von einem gutachter bewertet werden
müssten
bislang gibt es bereits vier länder die
ähnliche steuern haben die schweiz
belgien norwegen und spanien
wir werden euch über diese länder in
einem anderen video mehr erzählen aber
die wahrheit ist das ist eine bessere
formel für die besteuerung der reichen
gibt und zwar mit einer erbschaftssteuer
die erbschaftssteuer ist der betrag den
wir jedes mal zahlen müssen wenn wir
geld erben und sie hat wirklich einen
ähnlichen effekt wie die vermögenssteuer
es ist nur so dass man anstatt jedes
jahr einen prozentsatz des
nettovermögens abzuführen während man
noch lebt die steuern erst nach dem tod
löhnen muss
deutschland und viele andere länder
haben ein solches erbschaftsteuerrecht
allerdings wird über das thema
erbschaftssteuer und ihre moralische
begründung ständig debattiert viele von
euch denken vielleicht es handelt sich
im grunde um eine gute sache da ist ja
ungerecht sei reich geboren zu werden
andere mögen denken es sei aber noch
viel weniger fair wenn mehr als die
hälfte des von einer person während
ihres gesamten lebens geschaffenen
vermögens am ende des lebens an die
staatskasse abgeführt werden muss zumal
es sich um vermögen handelt das ja aus
bereits versteuerten einkommen angespart
wurde wenn wir alle die steuern die man
zu lebzeiten bezahlen musste und die
erbschaftsteuer die sich der staat nach
dem tod nimmt aufsummiert leid ein ende
wirklich nicht viel übrig
aber auch dies ist eine debatte die wir
uns für weitere videos auch sparen was
wir euch aber heute aufzeigen wollen ist
was im extremsten fall der erbschafts
besteuerung passiert und wo denn ihr
kommt es zu diesem extremfall natürlich
ausgerechnet in südkorea passt auf denn
jetzt kommt unser alter freund
der vorstandsvorsitzende von samsung ins
spiel
das geheimnis des ewigen lebens
südkorea ist eines der wohlhabendsten
länder der welt was bedeutet dass es
dort sehr viele reiche menschen gibt
allerdings gibt es bei den
südkoreanischen superreichen eine
besonderheit 74 prozent der dortigen
reagiere haben ihr vermögen geerbt falls
ihr visuelle politik schon länger
abonniert habt wisst ihr dass die
südkoreanische wirtschaft auf den
sogenannten thibault basiert übrigens
wenn ihr visual politik immer noch nicht
abonniert habt solltet ihr das genau
jetzt tun die so weil wir euch auf
diesen kanal erklären wie die dinge und
zusammenhänge in den verschiedensten
ländern der erde funktionieren und nur
über den talaren blickt blickt auch
durch kann vergleiche ziehen und die
lage in der welt und bei sich daheim
richtig einschätzen und daraus dann die
richtigen entscheidungen für sich
treffen zu können
wo sonst würdest du etwas über
erbschaftssteuern in südkorea erfahren
klick also schnell auch abonnieren und
auch auf die klingel damit um keinen
wertvollen beitrag mehr verpasst gut
genug der einwerbung und jetzt zurück zu
unserer geschichte unternehmen wie
samsung lg und hyundai wurden zu den
giganten diese heute sind weil sie eng
mit dem staat verflochten sind
und all diese teams haben etwas
gemeinsam sie sind familienunternehmen
samsung zum beispiel wurde von diesem
mann gegründet libyen schon als er starb
erbte sein sohn die firma und sein
vermögen dieser sohn ist unser freund
barney und an den tag an dem er stirbt
wird sein sohn james
das ganze family business während der
herr papa nun also gleichzeitig tot und
lebendig ist ist er derjenige der nicht
mehr macht tatsächlich leidet mit
anderen worten korea ist kein land in
dem ein null anfängt wie im silicon
valley
aus diesem grunde hat südkorea die
zweithöchste erbschaftssteuer aller
länder welche nur von japan übertroffen
wird in südkorea muss man bis zu 65
prozent des geerbten vermögens als
steuer abführen ja ihr habt richtig
gehört man da am ende nur 35 prozent
seines erbes behalten also etwas mehr
als ein drittel und viele von euch
werden jetzt einwenden 35 prozent eines
riesigen vermögens sind immer noch
ordentlich viel knete nicht wahr
das habe sein erbe könnte bis zu 15
milliarden dollar betragen nicht
schlecht oder
nun das problem ist dass wir hier nicht
über geld reden dann über anlagevermögen
und deshalb kann es ein großes problem
sein einen milliardärs vater in südkorea
zu haben
[Musik]
koreanische unternehmen sind entsetzt
über die schädliche höhe des
erbschaftsteuer satzes der zu den
höchsten der welt gehört denkt mal
darüber nach bei diesen 15 milliarden us
dollar handelt es sich nicht um geld auf
dem konto oder unter dem kopfkissen
sondern vor allem umsonst oder aktien
die umgerechnet 7 milliarden dollar
erbschaftsteuer jedoch die dann an den
fiskus fällig werden müssen in harter
währung bezahlt werden mit anderen
worten der sohnemann müsste die anteile
seines vaters an der firma verkaufen und
ihr fragt euch es vielleicht wie viele
aktien müsste er genau verkaufen um
seine steuerschuld zu begleichen
dies hängt von zwei faktoren ab erstens
vom aktienkurs zu todeszeitpunkt des
vaters und zweitens vom aktienkurs zu
dem zeitpunkt an dem er sie verkaufen
will und mannomann die samsung familie
könnte keine größere pechsträhne haben
[Musik]
gerüchte über den tod des samsung
konzernchefs kann hier lässt die
aktienkurse steigen ganz genau egal ob
über lg hyundai oder korean air sprechen
alle ihre eigentümerfamilien stehen vor
dem gleichen problem aber samsung
situation ist die unglaublichste von
allen denn die aktien von samsung hören
einfach nicht aufzusteigen das bedeutet
dass die erb summe immer weiter
anschwillt aber das ist noch nicht alles
wenn man plötzlich eine so große menge
an aktien auf einen schlag verkaufen
muss was passiert dann mit dem
marktpreis natürlich wird dieser sofort
einbrechen das bedeutet im endeffekt
dass das erbe des armen ebay an nach
steuern auf einen vince betrag zusammen
schmelzen könnte
das heißt keine knete und vor allem
keine eigentums und stimmrechte am
familienunternehmen mehr
und das erklärt warum er bereit ist
alles zu tun um seinem vater am leben zu
erhalten
[Musik]
auch elf monate nach dem herzinfarkt des
vorstandsvorsitzenden von samsung
electronics ag hält das samsung medical
center und der größte konzern des landes
den gesundheitszustand seines chefs und
die zukunft seines managements unter
einem dicken schleier der geheimhaltung
verhüllt inzwischen versuchte als
samsung sohn einen deal mit der
südkoreanischen regierung abzuschließen
um die erbschaftsteuer nach und nach
bezahlen zu können aber das wird nicht
einfach sein
sein verhältnis zum neuen koreanischen
präsidenten monarchie in könnte nicht
schlechter sein
[Musik]
samsung aber nach korruptions urteil zu
fünf jahren gefängnis verurteilt ganz
genau
samsung war in einen korruptionsskandal
verwickelt weil sie den vorherigen
präsidenten der zur gegnerischen partei
des jetzigen gehörte bestochen haben und
tag für tag kommen immer neue noch
schlimmere details über diesen
korruptionsskandal ans tageslicht dass
milliardär session wird sich erneut vor
gericht verantworten müssen und er
könnte dabei alle strafmilderung
verlieren über die er verfügt und
ungeachtet dessen wächst in der
zwischenzeit der kurs der samsung aktien
einfach weiter und weiter
seit 2016 hat sich wert verdoppelt
einzige lösung für unseren freund
besteht also darin auf den straßen von
seoul die menschen anzugehen bitte hört
auf aktien von samsung zu kaufen warum
investiert nicht in irgendwas anderes
apple-produkt o währungen ich meine
schaut samsung ist wirklich alles okay
klar aber so heißt es du nun auch wieder
nicht schaue mal am ende könntest du
wirklich enttäuscht sein
inzwischen hat der samsung patriarch
jedoch das geheimnis des ewigen lebens
gefunden seitdem er nach seinem
herzinfarkt im jahre 2014 im krankenhaus
verschwunden ist hat ihn niemand außer
seiner familie mehr gesicht
[Musik]
aber er ist weiterhin der chef der firma
samsung zumindest auf dem papier und
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
funktioniert diese erbschaftsteuer
wirklich ist südkorea ein paradies der
einkommensgerechtigkeit nun die wahrheit
ist nicht wirklich schaut obwohl wir die
soziale mobilität nicht gut messen
können können wir die einkommens und
vermögensverteilung durchaus gut
bestimmen wie mit dem genie index ihr
sehen wir das in südkorea die verteilung
nicht besonders ungleich aber auch nicht
besonders gleich ist in deutschland
großbritannien und sogar der
tschechischen republik in der es gar
keine erbschaftsteuer mehr gibt sind
vermögen und einkommen weitaus
gleichmäßiger verteilt als in korea
aber das ist natürlich ein thema für
anderes video nun kommt die frage an
euch werdet ihr eine noch höhere
erbschaftssteuer als in südkorea
was haltet ihr von einer vermögenssteuer
wie sie von elisabeth wollen tom petty
oder olaf scholz gefordert wird und was
glaubst du was mit samsung chef
passieren wird wird er endgültig zu
grabe getragen werden oder doch um den
toten auferstehen wie einst der heiland
bitte hinterlasst eure antworten im
moment aber reich und riefen video
abonniert visual politik und drückt auf
die klingel taste wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat dann gebt uns auch einen
daumen hoch und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]